jamais été du mauvais côté de la force
toujours du bon côté et puis je vois pas
pourquoi je basculerai de l'autre côté
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle sexe et je suis à
coeur éthique coeur éthique c'est une
personne qui va travailler dans la
sécurité informatique qui va vraiment
être là pour aider les différentes
entreprises dans n'importe quel secteur
dans le secteur un peu des banques de la
finance industriels à améliorer leurs
systèmes leurs systèmes informatiques
[Musique]
on a toujours eu un peu l'idée du hacker
ces méchants qui va piller les données
aller les revendre sur le dark web par
exemple alors qu'à la base d'un hacker
quand on prend un peu l'étymologie du
terme c'est vraiment une personne qui
est là pour améliorer aider à sécuriser
notre démocratie les différentes
applications qu'on va utiliser au
quotidien même des applications que moi
aussi j'utilise à coeur c'est plus en
fait au sein de la communauté en dehors
mais aujourd'hui dans les entreprises on
va plus parler de l'ingénieur en
cybersécurité pour moi je suis ingénieur
en cybersécurité donc je travaille pour
une grossesse à l'enfance et en dehors
de saab avec un peu mes autres amis
d'expression donc notre team de hacking
et donc fait les compétitions de
cybersécurité on a que des systèmes
toujours dans le vent avec le que le 4
le côté le cadre très légal de la chose
[Musique]
un vrai impact sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui un peu au niveau
géopolitique politique au niveau juste
en fait d'internet de pouvoir un peu
venir améliorer la sécurité de ces flics
de ses applications là c'est en faisant
un peu du bug bounty le big beauty c'est
le fait de venait de pouvoir un peu
trouver des vulnérabilités dans des
systèmes d'information et d'être
rémunérés en fonction de la faille qu'on
va trouver le bug bounty et le et le
hacking ne vont pas forcément de pair
pour lui il ya des hackers qui font pas
du tout bug bounty et qui a deux de
manière totalement différente
il ya un peu des gens aujourd'hui on
peut être du coup des bio hackers qui
vont un peu travaillé sur les prochaines
évolutions une prochaine évolution au
niveau de la cybersécurité et vu qu'on
parle aussi un moment aujourd'hui du
transhumanisme tout ce qui est politique
de tout ce qui en fait et qui va être un
peu de l'homme augmenté donc il est un
peu un moment dit un peu l'implantation
de puces donc la prise en main à
distance un peu d'un pacemaker par
exemple ou encore d'une puce dans le
bras dans le cerveau donc enfin il ya
aussi les personnes qui m'ont aidé à ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eric a aucune compétence juste une qui
prime au dessus de tout penser en dehors
du cadre
plus on est imaginatif plus on est
créatif et mieux c'est comme certains
diraient la seule limite c'est un peu
notre imagination
une des principales qualités à avoir
c'est un peu d'être et curieux et
surtout ne pas du tout pensé dans le
cadre qu'on veut nous imposer c'est un
peu comme ça qu'on va trouver les plus
gros ceux venant habiter ou parfois des
choses qui sont juste aberrante alors
qu'elles ne devraient pas être